I would never invite work friends to a
birthday party
oh I will take an open bar any day work
pleasure bad combo no there's not look
work pleasure oh it's a fiesta bond you
want some it's worth 30 on a Tuesday a
little I can't show you guys the real
meal look at Kalin uh is this guy
bothering you no oh okay
hey is that guy bothering you yeah
that's a move that can't possibly ever
work no probability man well I don't
want to know what my drunk pick-up line
is into a crazy or anything by the way
this is number five
[Applause]
I mean it also great over but pretties
asking her what our sign is so it turns
out if you drill a hole through the
center of a hot dog and then replace the
core with like some even lower quality
meat consumers can't even tell the
difference no idea business consultant
would know so much about meat oh well we
consultants are ready to handle any
consumer needs I can just picture you
out there on the factory floor walking
around in those cloud shoes what like
sanitary boots yeah gotta give me some
of them booties what is it you do I'm
not really sure if I was ready to meet
someone I wouldn't just pick them up in
a bar but you're not meeting anyone
anywhere I did online that way I know
exactly what I'm gonna get wow that is
only a celebration of life serendipity
it's like having a baseball card of the
person before you that's incredible
Hey hi this guy bothering you
no anyway so is that shoes yeah he's
bothering me
he actually bothering you no no Hamill
it I'm talking about statues I love
statues they're like paintings but more
okay um we are trying to have a
conversation can you stop bothering us
Harper Harper
if I came up to you tomorrow would you
pick up on come on I know too much about
you at this point to answer that
honestly is that bad
I mean like it's I know you're hard
worker and very driven competent
dependable
we're like a golden retriever so people
want that honey you just don't seem to
get caught out what I I would totally
put out oh yeah
bartender and get me a tequila de los
Muertos
she means a fiesta bomb a fiesta bomb
cookies you'll see you don't have to do
this
bums me
I
watch this hey hey
when Fiesta bomb for this sailor really
nice in your way hey are you interested
in putting out I put it up oh listen
long day I'm just kind of have a drink
here and hey is this guy bothering you
Anna yes yes he is
hey man don't you beat it
gladly those are nicest thing anyone's
ever dancing it's like the nicest thing
I've ever done for anyone
[Music]
[Music]
my lady I
I left my wallet at home did you get
these for me
[Music]
you